The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Before I
continue with the material,
I want to show you at least
the title of a recent paper
in Nature, because it's
related to material
we have covered in this course.
It's about the Kerr
effect, the effect
that one photon can create a
phase shift for another photon.
And one goal, of course,
for quantum computation
where things are
about single photons
is to have a
single-photon Kerr effect
that one photon can change
the phase of the other photon
in a strong, noticeable way.
So maybe one photon should
create a phase shift
on the order of pi.
And this was reported
here in this paper.
Of course, the non-linearity
created by nonlinear crystals
is much too weak for that.
But what those authors did is
they used microwave photos,
had microwave photons
into cavities.
And they were coupled
through a sapphire substrate
with a Josephson junction.
So the non-linearity
here is the non-linearity
of a Josephson junction,
which is actually
realized with a
superconducting qubit.
I can't explain you
many more details,
but I just thought
it sort of cool
to see how the Kerr
effect, which we discussed
and which we discussed
for single-photon,
is realized, at least
in the microwave domain.
And also, just sort
of to illustrate
that I hope this course enables
you to read recent research
papers, what those
people measured
is a [? key ?] representation.
This is a coherent state.
And then they showed, and this
is the subject of the paper,
that the coherent state which
has a well-defined phase,
lost its phase through
the Kerr medium.
And you clearly see there
is a big phase uncertainty.
But then after certain
time-- this is experiment
and this is simulation--
there is a re-phasing,
and the phase is back.
There is a revival of
the coherent state.
All right.
Now I want to address
one question which
Cody asked about the g2
function and fluctuations
of single-mode light.
Let me just summarize.
I told you that if you
do the thermodynamics
of a single mode, we find
Bose-Einstein distribution
of photons.
And we have a
thermal distribution.
And a thermal distribution means
sometimes we have more photons,
sometimes we have less
photons, depending
on the thermal distribution.
And when we calculated what the
intensity fluctuations were,
we found they're characterized
by a g2 function of 2.
OK.
Then a little bit later
in this course-- actually,
just this week-- I told you
that single-mode light always
has a g2 function of one.
And what I meant here is the
following, rather trivial.
If you have a single mode,
that means that you [? align ?]
[? it ?] is simply
e to the i omega t,
the intensity is constant.
There are no intensity
fluctuations.
And also, because everything
is sort of predictable,
it's just one wave.
The Gn function
factorizes into-- can
be re-expressed by
the g1 function.
So therefore, this is
the most trivial case.
But the question
now is, how do we
reconcile those two statements,
that a single mode, e to the i
omega t, does not have
intensity fluctuations?
Therefore, is a g2
function of one.
And our earlier treatment
about single-mode black-body
radiation.
And of course, the
answer is, what
is the single mode
in one context
is different from the single
mode in the other context.
Maybe let me explain that.
Let's just create an
ensemble of cavities.
We put them in thermal
contact with a reservoir.
And then we break the thermal
Each cavity has now a
perfect single mode, e
to the i omega t.
But each cavity is filled
with a different photon number
according to the
thermal statistics.
So therefore, if you
just look at one cavity,
we find no intensity
fluctuations.
The g2 function is one.
But if you extend
the ensemble average
over all the
different cavities, we
find that there are
fluctuations in intensity.
Well, we can now
keep that in mind.
But now we can say,
well, let's just
take one cavity which is weakly
coupled to a thermal reservoir.
And instead of looking
at the ensemble average
of many cavities, we look
at the long-time average
of this one cavity.
And what will happen is thermal
photons will be created,
will disappear, and such.
So now this one
cavity fluctuates.
But technically,
what that means now
is it means that the
sharp mode of the cavity
is interacting with
the environment,
and it becomes broadened.
It has a broadening delta omega.
And this can be
regarded as that we
mix in modes of the environment.
So in that case,
strictly speaking,
it's no longer a
single-mode cavity.
So you have to
consider those things.
And depending what point
of view you want to take,
you get the different result.
Other questions?
Then let me ask you a question.
Last class, I explained
to you-- well, at least,
tried to explain to you
that g2 function for bosons
and fermions with the
counting statistics,
with permutations and such.
I wasn't sure, at
least from one question
I got, whether this
was completely clear.
Do you have any
question about that?
[? Teroy. ?]
AUDIENCE: This
seems very obvious.
But during class, I
was trying to something
with thermal state.
What is the definition
of our thermal state
in terms of any basis,
just generally speaking?
We write it as-- I thought
it'd be something like e
to the minus beta
light Hamiltonian.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So our definition of
the thermal state--
when we had thermal
light, we say
that the statistical
operator is given by that.
And H is the Hamiltonian
for a single-mode light,
which is n plus 1/2 nn.
Well, with suitable
parentheses and summations.
Other questions?
OK.
Then let's get to the main
subject we want to discuss now.
And these are actually
Feynman diagrams.
I wanted to give you
an exact definition
and a deep
understanding, what does
it mean when we talk about
processes of absorption
and emission, but also about
absorption, emission processes
which violate energy.
And some people refer to
them as virtual photons.
The reason is that virtual
photons cannot really exist
for a long time.
When you emit a virtual
photon, another photon
has to be absorbed immediately
to reconcile energy
conservation, as we
want to see in a moment.
So the goal of this
presentation is
I want you that you realize
that each of those doodles
has an exact
mathematical meaning.
Each of those diagrams
represents one term,
or a class of terms,
in an exact solution
for the time evolution
of the system.
So in other words,
if you would ask me,
we have a ground
and excited state.
Is it possible that the
ground state emits a photon,
goes to a virtual state,
emits another photon
of another frequency, and then
somehow absorbs the photon,
goes to here, and eventually
takes another photon,
and is back to the ground state.
Is that a possibility?
Can that happen?
And I think what
the message here
is yes, everything happens.
The system is trying out
all of its possibility.
And the two time
evolution is the sum
of all those possibilities,
of all the amplitudes related
to those diagrams.
But what I want to show you
is how sort of the weirder
the diagrams get, the more you
go in energy below the ground
state, the more you go away
from real atomic states,
the bigger is your
energy denominator.
And that means
those diagrams have
a smaller and smaller weight.
And in all practical
calculations, we neglect those.
But I want you sort of to be
able to see that and realize,
I exactly know what it means.
It means this and this
term in a summation
over all the amplitudes
which the quantum
system is exploring.
And I think with that, we really
learn something about physics.
We learn about what is
actually inside the Schrodinger
equation.
A lot of people actually,
before they take this class,
think that this
is just nonsense,
that this has no
physical reality.
But I hope after
this class, you see
that pretty much everything
you draw has physical reality.
It's just-- it may
not contribute a lot.
So what we have done--
and let me just start here
and invite your questions.
We have figured out how
an initial state evolves
with a time evolution operator
to another basis state,
toward the final state.
And formally, this is the formal
solution and exact solution
of the Schrodinger equation.
We have to sum over all orders,
orders in the interaction.
Well, I will
immediately tell you
what is the first
and second order.
We are not going much higher.
But if you want, here, you can.
And then what you have to
do is in the time evolution,
you have to sum over
intermediate times.
You have to allow the system to
propagate, to change its state,
propagate again,
change its state again.
And the times where the
change of state happens,
that can happen at any
time between your initial
and your final time.
And we integrate over
all possible times.
And I showed you--
and I think this
was the very last thing
we did on Wednesday.
I showed you how
this diagram can
be translated into
mathematical equation.
And I think I picked the
second order diagram.
But I think from the way how I
presented should be clear now
how any such diagram can be
translated into an equation.
And eventually, you have
to perform an integral
over all intermediate times.
And this is part of the time
evolution of the system.
Questions about that?
AUDIENCE: We allowed these
to be [INAUDIBLE] right?
Because we haven't done
anything with that?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
I assume that it's
time-independent.
Actually, right now, I assume,
just to assume something,
that it's a dipole interaction.
My understanding is if it has
an explicit time dependence,
it would just appear there,
and it would not change the--
would it?
Wait, would it?
Actually, when be derived
the differential equation
for the time evolution
operator, did
we assume that v was
time-independent or not?
I don't think we did.
We integrate over time.
I think the formal solution.
Remember, I wrote down
the differential equation
for the time evolution
operator and then say,
this is a formal solution.
My gut feeling is
nothing changes
when v is time-independent,
but this one step
should be confirmed.
Other questions?
OK.
Then let me just spend a few
minutes on connecting what we
have done with standard
first and second
[? auto-perturbation ?] theory.
I want to sort of throw
a few definitions at you.
S-matrix, T-matrix.
But I'm not really
going into any details.
I just want to sort of wrap
up the perturbative treatment
by connecting it with the
standard first and second
[? auto-perturbation ?] theory.
But after that in
a few minutes, I
want to have a discussion
about the nature
of intermediate and
so-called virtual state,
and then talk about the
interaction v, whether it's
d, dot, e; or the p
minus e interaction.
OK.
So far, I've presented
the formalism
that we started in initial
time and ended at final time.
But usually, these
are microscopic times.
And in the
experiment, we observe
a system for macroscopic time.
So for that purpose, we
usually go to the limit
that initial and final
times are infinitely apart.
And that actually means we
have energy conservation.
The initial and final
energy has to be the same.
And that can be, for instance,
even if you restrict ourselves
to second order, remember we
had all those propagators,
e to the i energy
over H bar times t.
And when we integrated
over long times,
it will just average
out to zero unless
the initial and final
energy are the same.
And technically,
you have seen that
in undergraduate derivation
second order perturbation
theory.
You integrate the
exponential function.
And eventually, for
sufficiently long time,
capital T is the
difference between
initial and final times.
It approaches the
delta function.
So that's how energy
conservation comes in.
So the fact that we
have energy conservation
is then used to
define s and T-matrix.
The transition amplitude from
the initial to the final state,
what we have just
calculated and discussed,
is called the S-matrix.
It's just how it is called.
In first order, of
course, the time evolution
is the unitary matrix.
So therefore, we get
[? conical ?] delta.
And then we discussed that
in the limit of large times,
we have a delta function.
So therefore, if we
take the S-matrix, which
is the transition amplitudes
we have calculated,
and sort of take out of the
S-matrix, the unity matrix,
and factor out the delta
function, then what is left
is the so-called T-matrix.
When we talk about transition
amplitude, transition
probabilities, we
are asking, what
is the probability
that the system
has gone from an initial
state, maybe the ground--
the excited state
to the ground state
through spontaneous emission?
Well, probability is
an amplitude squared.
So we take the matrix element
of the S-matrix and square it.
And from the line
above, this is now
involving the matrix element
of the T-matrix squared.
There's a delta
function which becomes
a delta function squared.
But if you integrate over all
final states, that's-- I mean,
a delta function is always
requiring that you do some
integration later.
Otherwise, the delta
function doesn't make sense.
The delta function squared.
You can actually explicitly see
from the sine function above.
The delta function squared
just turns into the time t.
So therefore, if you divide
the probability by the time,
we have our transition
probability.
We have our transition rate.
And what we obtain is the
second order expression
for the transition rate, which
is essentially Fermi's Golden
Rule.
So anyway, this
is just finishing
the formal derivation.
But now I want to
discuss the nature
of those intermediate states.
And maybe what you
should have in mind--
the intermediate state, which
comes about when we have
the system in the ground
state, it emits a photon
and goes down to this
intermediate state,
or this weird state which
seems to be lower in energy
than the ground state.
Well, what happens is those
intermediate states, when they
appear after the vertex, they
propagate with the energy.
But if their energy is less
than the initial energy,
here, the energy-- the
intermediate state k
has a phase factor
in its propagation
which is determined by the
difference of its energy
with the initial energy.
So when we violate
energy conservation
in intermediate state,
delta Ek is non-zero,
and it is the larger, the more
we violate energy conservation.
And then in the solution
of the time evolution,
we have to integrate over
all intermediate times.
So what we have here is we have
an oscillating phase vector.
And when we integrate it,
when we integrate something
oscillating over longer
than an oscillation period,
it averages out to zero.
So therefore, those
intermediate states
which are off the energy shell,
which seem to violate energy,
can only noticeably
contribute over
a duration which is 1 over
the energy defect, delta Ek.
So it is correct to say
that the system in its time
evolution for short
times can, so to speak,
violate energy protected
by Heisenberg's uncertainty
relation.
Or you can say, the system
can do whatever it wants.
It can spontaneously
create 10 photons.
But this is pretty much like
taking money, taking a deposit
out of Heisenberg's bank.
And after very,
very short time, you
have to pay it back by
having another process which
brings you back to
the correct energy.
I should put it under
quotation marks when
I said we violate energy,
because energy is not
sort of defined or measurable
in this intermediate times.
We start a process
with a quantum system,
we look what happens afterwards.
And whenever we
assess energy, it
is assessed when
the final time is
much, much larger
than the initial time.
And I just showed you that
eventually, the system
has to be back to
a final energy, Ef,
which is identical to
the initial time, Ei.
So in other words, I just
want you to keep it in mind.
I've proven to you
energy conservation
in the limit that t final
minus t initial is large.
And when I'm now talking about
non-conservation of energy,
I do that in quotation
marks, because we
know energy is
conserved in the end.
It's just that for very,
very short times in the time
evolution of the system, there
appear virtual states which
seem to violate energy.
But you can think
about it in that way.
Questions about that?
Finally, let me now
address the question,
is everything I'm explaining
to you really happening?
Is it really happening
in a physical system?
Well, the first answer
is, I wouldn't tell you
about it if it had no reality.
So yes.
You can imagine that this
is what your atom is doing.
You can imagine that
the hydrogen atom that's
[INAUDIBLE] [? shift ?]
is permanently
emitting and absorbing
photons and all sorts
of weird photons from
the ground state,
lower, up, and back
again, and such.
Yes.
This is the way
how we derive some
of the most precise predictions
in physics, namely QED.
However, we can represent
systems in different gauges,
in different representations.
And we had discussed
earlier that we often
take the dipole representation
for the light atom interaction.
But there's also the p
minus a representation.
And if you look at the two, both
the e, dot, d and the a, dot, p
interaction are the
product of something
which creates and annihilates
single photons-- a plus a
[? dega. ?] And then the p
operator or the d operator
connect the ground
with the excited state.
So those matrix
element would tell you,
you can only emit
and absorb a photon
when you go from the ground
to the excited state.
However, in the p
minus a representation,
we also have the a squared term.
And the a squared
term allows you--
because there is no atomic
operator in front of it--
allows you to
scatter two photons
without changing the
quantum state of the atom.
But this does not
contradict anything.
You can take either approach.
And in your homework,
you will actually
do that when you calculate
Rayleigh scattering and Thomson
scattering.
And you will find out
that the two approaches
give identical results.
So if you know ask the
philosophical question,
can an atom scatter a photon
without changing its quantum
state, well, the
answer to this question
is actually gauge-dependent.
But maybe to lift away
some of the confusion,
one can, of course,
also say, the a
squared term is
really important.
And it's a simple description
of Thomson scattering.
Thomson scattering
is about photons
which have much, much more
energy than the energy
difference between the
ground and excited state.
So therefore, if you want
to completely describe
the system-- and you can,
it's just more complicated--
with a dipole approximation,
we have to scatter a photon.
But because the photon
has so much more energy,
it's so far away from resonance,
this intermediate state
has a huge energy defect.
And that means what I
just explained to you--
the system wants to
immediately pay back
the money to Heisenberg's bank.
So it will remain in this state
only for very, very short time.
And now the other
gauge tells you,
this very, very short
time can also be zero.
So see, it's not as dramatically
different as you might assume.
But this is just
something which is common
that, if you have
different representations,
the physics tastes
different, but you always
have to remind you that when you
calculate an observable result,
the two different gauges
must exactly agree.
Questions?
All right.
So this is all I wanted to say
about the diagrammatic solution
for the time evolution
of a quantum system.
But I want to use it now.
I think this is
interesting stuff.
It's a powerful method.
And I want to illustrate
to you how this method can
be used in the
next two sections.
Our next section is van
der Waal's interactions.
So the chapter on van
der Waals interaction
is quite interesting for
the following reason.
It really tells us
something about the vacuum.
I think modern physics
has come to the conclusion
that the vacuum is one of
the most interesting subjects
to study, because
the vacuum is alive.
It's filled by virtual
photons, virtual particles.
And as we know now, by a
condensate of Higgs boson.
So there is a lot of
stuff, a lot of structure,
a lot of phenomena
associated in the vacuum.
And the subject of van
der Waals interactions
is it's a nice way to
talk about the vacuum,
but it's nice also for
the following reason.
There is a completely, I
would say, semi-classical way.
Just use the
Schrodinger equation
and calculate what
is the Van der Waals
interaction between two atoms.
So you can just calculate
in perturbation theory.
And in your whole
calculation, you never
use the quantized
electromagnetic field.
Photons never appear.
You just use
perturbation theory.
And you do that
in your homework.
It's rather straightforward.
And you could have Van
der Waals interaction.
On the other hand, I started
to derive for you the theory
of the quantized
electromagnetic field by saying,
we really look at everything.
We have charges, and we have
the electric and magnetic field.
And we described everything.
And the way how we
separate it is we
had this Hamiltonian H naught,
which gives us the atom.
And the longitudinal Coulomb
field became part of it.
So this is the degree
of freedom of the atom.
And we have H naught
for the other atom.
And then we had radiation
field and the coupling
to the atom described
by our operator V, which
can be the dipole operator
or can be written down
in other gauge.
But what I'm telling you is the
way how we have fundamentally
divided the world into atoms,
atom's neutral objects,
and the rest is interactions
with the radiation field.
That should tell you
that the Van der Waals
interaction between two atoms
must have a description in QED
where the Van der Waals
indirection between atoms
comes from the
exchange or photons.
So there are two very simple
pictures at the same physics.
One is you don't even
know that they're photons,
you just do perturbation theory.
But in a more
comprehensive description
where we include
the photons, you
should be able to
understand the Van der Waals
action between two atoms
due to the exchange
of virtual photons.
In other words, one atom
is in the ground state,
emits a photon that's going
down from the ground state.
But until now, if you
have only one atom,
it has to reabsorb the
photon again and be back
in the ground state.
Otherwise, energy
would be violated.
But if you have two atoms,
one atom can emit a photon,
and the other atom
can absorb it.
And then the other atom
can send a photon back.
And if we consider
that process, we
will actually find the
Van der Waals interaction.
So I hope this is showing
interesting physics from two
angles-- that something
which looked maybe
trivial a long
time ago now looks
much richer, because
those forces are really
mediated by virtual
photon pairs.
So that's sort of the
discussion I want to go through.
There is another aspect to it.
And this is when we go from
the Van der Waals force
to the Casimir force.
The Casimir force has
one exact derivation,
which I want to share with
you, which relates the Casimir
force to the vacuum fluctuations
of the electromagnetic field.
So eventually, for those
forces between two metal
plates-- a neutral
atom in the plate,
two neutral atoms-- we will
have three different pictures.
One is we use the
semi-classical dipole field
as a perturbation operator.
You don't think about it.
It's trivial, and you check
it off in your homework.
The second one is you
look at the exchange
of virtual photons.
And the third one
is you only look
at the zero-point fluctuations
of the electromagnetic field.
What is real here?
What causes it?
We'll see.